everyone and welcome to infectious
disease virtual event
my name is pheromones Ralph I remem a
professor of biomedical informatics at
San Diego State University I will be
presenting on the diagnosis and
treatment of tuberculosis the case
studying challenges and threats posed by
infectious diseases please feel free to
submit questions during my presentation
and I will follow up with you via Edith
now moving on okay I will be talking I
will be focusing on three specific areas
first on the epidemiology of the disease
next on the diagnostic challenges and
the last and the last point that I will
discuss are some destructive in emerging
technologies that offer the potential
for significant advances now first about
the transmission of the disease as we
all know tuberculosis is caused by
Mycobacterium tuberculosis it transmits
through the air usually cells that are
stuck together about two or three cells
at a time they travel through the air
and enter the Airways of a second host
usually if more than two or three cells
are stuck together they create a larger
mass than they become more difficult to
travel through the airways and so the
infectious potential of such large
analysis is actually lower no it's a
this is a bacterium that is a fairly
slow growing it multiplies about once
every 24 hours if you compare that to
say other even Marco bacterium snake
mantis which is in the same groove
straight America's gross multiplies
about once every half an hour so given
it's growing so slowly it's actually a
surprise that it has a spread so
successful in our own world
it plays well
the active form of the disease we see it
about 9 million times every year so 9
million new people are developed active
form of the disease 1.5 million die from
it and that's quite successful that and
if you count the estimation for the last
200 years is that 1 billion people have
died from this disease
that's quite a number compared to at the
Ebola outbreak that we have in 2011 or
2012 in that outbreak about 28,000
people died this disease kills 1.5
million every year so it's the biggest
infectious disease killer recently it
passed HIV and there are some very good
reasons why this is the most successful
human pathogen the first one is actually
this slow growth rate so this factory
girls are slowly as a result makes the
patient ill slowly and it kills the
hosts very slowly keep in mind that for
a pathogen like this tetra buckner
travels through the year if it kills the
host rapidly that also loses the ability
to infect other coasts so it's actually
a bandage for this pathogen to slowly
kill the host the other advantage that
it has is its great ability to regulate
its metabolism it's opportunistic it can
turn itself off and go into latency and
when the immune system is compromised
either because of a disease like HIV or
some trauma it can bring
activate itself and when it faces drug
pressure antibiotic treatment it also
has the ability to revert back to its
wettest so many cases were really think
that the disease has or the infection
has actually cleared the reality is that
it's reverted to its latency in us
waiting for the antibiotic pressure to
to be reduced there are several other
reasons one is HIV epidemic it works
synergistically with HIV and the
mortality rate is much higher in
hiv-positive populations the bacteria
makes HIV much more virulent and HIV
makes it easier for Mycobacterium
tuberculosis to enter the macrophage and
which is where it usually results then
the bacterium has this a serious ability
to rapidly adapt and when I say rapidly
this is a relative statement and it's
relative to his slow growth rate but
fairly soon after the introduction of
new antibiotics just happened the last
time in 2016
fairly soon the bacterium adapts and
resistance to those antibiotics emerge
already that resistance to antibiotics
that we introduced in 2016 already in
2017 we have that resistance emerging
when a disease spreads as broadly and as
widely as this one it also has the
ability to break down national control
programs and when that happens then the
disease spreads even fast and finally
that more recently migration has become
easier and this disease migrates with
the hosts all over the world so
among all those reasons why this
pathogen is so successful I wanted to
talk about resistance the first category
of resistance is called multi-drug
resistance and that's when the bacterium
becomes resistant to the two most
powerful drugs first-line threats that's
isoniazid and rifampicin and the matter
that you see on the screen shows how
widely spread this form of the disease
is in 2016 four hundred and ninety
thousand new cases of MDR TB but were
diagnosed and it is an estimation
because many of the people who suspect
they have this form of the disease they
actually there's a stigma attached when
they are lost to follow-up unfortunately
the treatment success for this variety
of the disease is about 50% and so
people who know this and they get the
message that they might have MDR TB
either they don't believe it or they
lose hope and they are lost to follow-up
the next level of resistance is
extensively drug drug resistance this is
the case when a MDR TB has been
established so resistance to rifampicin
and tyson Aizen has been determined
additionally the bacteria are resistant
to at least one fluoroquinolone group of
drugs and also one at least one
injectable group of drugs something like
amikacin cameras were catalyst so
incidence of XDR increased tenfold
between 2002 and 2012 this goes in the
face of some early assumptions that we
have that the more resistant the
bacteria becomes the less fit it becomes
because mutation
that cause resistance also have a
fitness cost and so initially there was
a thinking that the more resistant
bacteria wouldn't a spread but the
amount that you see says otherwise
and again unfortunately the success rate
in treatment of xdr-tb is even worse and
that's 34 percent now if that wasn't
enough we also have the category of
totally drug-resistant tuberculosis this
is an informal definition not adapted by
the World Health Organization's for many
reasons including political and because
it is informal it has different
definitions by different groups it was
first detected in Italy then it was
reported in India and South Africa and
several other countries have since
joined that group they prove in India
which were in collaborate and
collaborative group was our group they
reported a strain that was resistant to
23 different antibiotics the South
Africa group reported as strain that was
resistant to 9 both were referred to as
tdr TB by the respective groups now in
terms of Diagnostics as you can imagine
these different levels of resistance are
difficult to identify for many reasons
cost time but as well as the different
platforms that are needed to determine
all the resistant to all the different
drugs now what I'm showing on the screen
is a slide from that I have borrowed
from the WHL and it shows the different
categories of platforms that are
available
the most common platform is there is a
group of platforms dance
our growth based this means that they
grow their bacteria in presence of the
drug and there's a time as well as
colony size threshold so if within a
certain time the colony size become
certain betta size than they and
classified that bacteria as resistant if
it doesn't then is classified as
susceptible to that drug these are by
far the most common currently the next
group of diagnostic methods are
molecular based the biggest advantage of
these tests is that they are rabid
because this is a very slow growing
bacterial growth but it makes me nervous
typically takes several weeks sometimes
up to a month before we know that the
case is resistant to a certain drug and
during that one month I have the wrong
treatment is given and the pathogen has
the opportunity to infect others
molecular tests are rapid and typically
the results are known within days
there's a huge amount of development
going on right now at the Bark's that is
highlighted on the screen is the set
that is endorsed by WTO but there's a
whole lot of other platforms the
additional boxes on the side some are
scheduled to be tested by the WTO some
have not but are in public so there's a
large group there and finally there's a
group that is cannot be categorized as
any one of those two groups for example
microscopy that's used for detection of
TV but not typically for a determination
of resistance now I want to focus on
molecular diagnostics because that's it
holds the greatest potential for rapid
and accurate Diagnostics there's light
that you see describes why
the current platforms are facing a
challenge and let me back up and say
that the current platform should rely on
previous knowledge acquired through
research and that has identified targets
that these molecular diagnostic
platforms then include and they will
look at only those regions of the genome
and they see whether there are mutations
in those specific locations if there are
mutations then they will classify that
bacteria is resistant if there is no
mutation in that will commit locus then
they classify a society now what you see
on the screen is the list of first and
second line drugs the most common ones
you also see there in the second column
the lists of genes that are implicated
in emerging resistance to those struts
for example if I think I Sinai's catchy
and the promoter of
inha are the low-side that commonly be
seen in patients that cause resistance
for rifampicin another first line drug
ARP you need is as the most common gene
and when when we say gene usually there
are hot spots within those gene so it's
not the entire gene that is the
mutations cause resistance in our pili
for example there's a reformist
indeterminant region referred to as our
RDR that mutations in that region are
assumed to cause resistance now the
biggest problem here is the third column
has shown in the third column as you can
see the sensitivity of the mutations
that we have so far discovered you know
identifying resistance to these drugs is
a bit far from the
that we would like you to be the best
one is Robinson is the one that is is
the model that is working the best but
as you can see for instance for Kira
myosin that percentage drops down to
high salaries this offers to challenges
and concerns one is that about 20%
depending on the drug of course of
resistant cases we will miss if we
exclusively use these types of numerator
darkness platforms these are unusual
cases where they don't have the expected
mutations but still they are
phenotypically resistant so some
challenges that those who work in the
area of developing molecular diagnostics
need to face first is that there could
be alternative mechanisms of resistance
and this has been shown already by many
groups including my own group that these
do exist and so as a result a platform
that is focused to detect mutations in a
specific locus will miss these other
alternative mechanisms the sort of
typical solution here is to use whole
genome sequencing but even then there
are further complications for example
epistasis could could complicate things
enormously that's when multiple
mutations work together to make a case
resist in such a case it's not just
another mutation in the genome that
you're looking for but another set of
mutations so so far people who have been
trying to find
epistatic effects that cause resistance
they typically use whole genome
sequencing and then they do
combinatorial analysis from the
computing point of view this has the
challenge that community 11 Alice's when
you have thousands of mutations is an
empty complete problem that means that
the solution for it exists in terms of
coding and programming but it only
exists but it's only feasible for
problems that are small once the count
of mutations become thousands across the
genome it will take enormous amount of
time to write and run that code and so
that's one problem and the other problem
is the curse of dimensionality which is
you have thousands of mutations but you
only have several hundred patients at a
time in order to explore that high
dimensional space you really require
tens of thousands if not hundreds of
thousands of patients and that's
infeasible kernston's lots of effort oh
we have little to show for I believe
that the paradigm shift there is needed
and I'll talk a little bit about that
shift in the next few slides the other
challenge that we have that the
molecular diagnostic community as a
whole has been ignoring to a great deal
so far but now they are starting to
consider that as a distinct challenge
that needs to be addressed and that's
hither engine 8 this is when a patient
is the host to multiple populations in
the simplest case one population is
susceptible to a drug but a small
population is resistant in such a case
would we apply the antibiotics systemic
treatment they will wipe out the
population that is susceptible this
small subpopulation will survive grow
and is actually the one causing the
infection that act of perfection so
because that's a population is so small
at the beginning it is difficult
pet and therefore most patients like
that are classified as susceptible
through phenotyping approaches those are
the groasis approaches the sensitivity
to detect a subpopulation and is
resistant ranges between one to ten
percent that depends on the drug however
on the molecular side we are lacking
commonly when we do molecular analysis
we take the most frequent allele and so
that means that we are going to miss any
subpopulations of the smaller than 50
percent current status there's quite a
bit of development in that area actually
concerned hopeful that this challenge
will be a mostly addressed in the near
future improvement and sequencing
technology will greatly help especially
if we can develop the ability to
sequence directly from the sputum it
will be very helpful the other part of
this is epigenetics and epigenetics
is the area that most molecular
diagnostic platforms are completely
ignoring right now it's fully in
research that we run into this but it's
been shown by several groups including
our own that epigenetics actually play
an active role in emergence of new
phenotypes may play a role in adaptation
they are the mechanisms that the
bacteria use for rapid response to
environmental pressure and therefore
they are instrumental to the bus ability
to survive and eventually tripping off
on the coexistence we are currently in
early stages of this a new tool
development is underway moving out of my
own mouth and again I think we will see
some significant advances in this area
in the near future now a few things
about this factor
in order for us to understand what the
challenges are first this has a circular
genome that is for about 4.4 mega bases
long unfortunately 40% of the genome is
genetic Dartmouth our meaning that we
don't actually know what that 40% does
and also unfortunately it's a threat to
genome with many small and large repeats
this presents a challenge for short read
sequencing that has become so popular
these days
take for instance aluminum many of the
repeats are so large that alumina short
reads cannot not the genome is circular
as I mentioned but it is unbalanced it's
a very GC rich genome this also presents
a challenge for sequencing platforms
that have an amplification step built
into the library prep and the pre
sequence accepts the G Series inner
regions do not equally amplify and that
presents a an artificially different
view of those regions as compared to a
result eg culture preparation and DNA
extraction takes variably
long time I talked about how long it
takes for it to grow these bacteria but
also for reasons we don't fully
understand certain strains grown a bit
faster certain grow slower so for
platforms like Illumina that offer
cheaper rows because of the economies of
scale it becomes a challenge to run the
DNA of several strains together unless
you are running a laboratory that is
tied to a to a clinic that deals with a
lot of cases about tuberculosis
so specifically I want to focus on the
challenges that the this genome offers
to short breathe sequencing come here I
wanna highlight we don't know because
it's the most popular short read whole
genome sequencing platform out there
what you see on the background is the
genome of M tuberculosis map dust inner
circle and then the second circle frame
from the center is the GC content of
that region of of the genome and what
you see also is a our red circles around
in the third layer and those are the
blurring spots that you see and almost
wearing what that means
first the causes for these Florence was
these are spots where alumina has a
difficult time to sequence there are two
main causes one is the high GC content
as I mentioned and the second is the
amplification bias the third one that I
have forgotten to list here is those
repeat reaches consequences inflated
variation rate at some mosa and also
missing important mechanisms in
genome-wide Association studies so as I
mentioned I described the first three
circles the red one is the blind spots
at the aqua color the color circle
denotes the repeat regions that shows
where the repeat segments are and the
last one outer circle is regions where
there is very high GC content and what
you can see in comparing is that first
of all if you put the whole thing
together you'll see that these blind
spots are scattered all over the genome
they are not focused in one area and
then the
about 3.5 3.2 percent of the genome and
that's roughly alternative 50,000 bases
so that's not a small amount many blind
spots are explained by the high GC
content as you can see did at last three
circles overlap but some and cannot be
displayed by these we don't fully
understand why these blind spots are
there we use several thousand aleena
genomes that were publicly available to
discover these these blind spots
therefore and these are common problems
by the platform now these blind spots
functionally they scattered across
multiple functional domains of course
the largest is the group of P and P peds
these are genes that are interact with
the host immune system and it said
defensemen is the primary difference
mechanism of the pathogen these are
mostly unknown genes their functions are
not clear beyond what I just mentioned
and unfortunately these boring spots
seem to be popular among these genes and
perhaps the reason why these are not
studied so on but there are other
functional groups as well the red is the
group of hypothetical genes that's the
Dark Matter genome at dark matter that I
wish we don't know what they do
emergency solutions laundry sequencing
has solved many of these problems it is
still in the experimental phase but some
really exciting discoveries are already
being reported showing three reports
published just recently inside the
victor of course as well as nucleic acid
research using a pack viruses for
sequencing two
report novel discoveries in the genome
but also in the middle of in the on the
epigenetic front this is our pipeline
how we use PacBio
we have a pipeline that performs the
normal Assembly circularization
consensus polishing and then a
methylation of the texture and assembly
QC this pipeline not only assembles the
genomes to normal
and so we have a full view of the
genomes circularized
including those repeat regions and high
GC content but we also assembled the
methalone and we are able to assess
epigenetic changes that may be
associated the certain phenotypes under
genetic fronts this is the first of our
publications that were not a couple
years ago and this correct that the
genetic basis for virulence that was
earlier reported we did this study on
page 37 RA that has the attenuated
virulence
it's the Avery wealth version of
tuberculosis and that strain was
compared to the pyramid versions and the
differences were so it were attributed
to the genetic differences that cost
parallels when we see courses with
PacBio circularized and had been
assembled in de novo genome and that
circularized
we realized that most of those
differences were actually sequencing
errors and so we had published our
results in this manuscript alternative
mechanisms of resistance I mentioned us
as a as a
a huge challenge in the First Minister's
on the table
we recorded 11 new mechanisms new
mutations that cause resistance these
are the ones that are commonly missed by
typical molecular platforms today that's
a big concern because we are really
applying so sort of a type of selection
we are classifying those resistant cases
as susceptible allowing them to spread
while we capture the most travel of
mechanisms and eradicate in the second
manuscript that I listed on yellow we'd
never see had some molecular dynamics
and demonstrated how those mutations
cause resistance by basically strangling
their channels that go to the heme
inside of the cap g-protein so that was
Ison eyes it one of the most powerful
first-line drugs P ressentiment is the
second drug from among the first-line
drugs that we studied and in the top -
spirit we reported over a hundred new
mutations that cause resistance and in
the manuscript down below we didn't
wondered if we discover so many how many
others have other people other groups
have the story when we put all of that
together in a systematic review the
result came to about a thousand
different mutations in a single gene and
that result was quite spectacular and
that study has been referenced a number
of times over what we have learned this
is sort of a summary of everything that
I've said majority of genomic changes is
not due to point in tissues this is not
something that got into but it's a
summary from everything that we've done
in this
using long reach sequencing on average
in an M tuberculosis genome about 2,000
computations we discover however 50,000
bases are affected by all these other
types of genomic changes we completely
are ignoring those changes at this point
through molecular diagnosis this is a
big concern on all explained in minute
why other types of variations could
render point mutations inconsequential
so imagine a gene that is rendered
unexpressed but we look at the mutation
inside that gene to determine whether
whether that bacterium is resistant
whether that gene has a mutation or not
is inconsequential if that gene is not
being expressed and that fact we are
completely ignored at this point
phenotypic you know to be discordance
can compromise the diagnostic attackers
absence of the complete genome due to DC
bias or repeats is a is a big loser
heterogeneity is also a big concern we
need to do a much better job in finding
smaller sub populations and TB is
evolving differently in different parts
of the world this has to do partly with
the regimens that we choose in different
parts of the world but also partly
because of the ways we diagnose
resistance if we use molecular diagnosis
in one part of the world and then we use
our treatment decisions based on that we
are likely to preferentially select for
resistant mechanisms that are not common
and that is a huge risk what we predict
is
a feat on this world few years down the
road we will have a reemergence of
resistance but this time with a very
diverse set of mechanisms all the ones
that we are missing today epigenetics
plays a key role in persistence and the
emergence of resistance we are
completely ignoring that right now
however a few groups around the world
are paying attention to that and so new
tools hopefully will emerge learning the
evolutionary steps Lavar allow us to
develop and to detect the phenotypes
much earlier hopefully before that
phenotype has set forth and emerged we
can also develop much-needed prognostic
tools in addition to comprehensive
diagnostic students the goal there is
can we predict the evolutionary path of
a pathogen given a regimen that has been
used for treatment if we can then
perhaps we can predict the emergence of
resistance before it thus started by
changing a treatment current molecular
diagnostics as a way should act as a
selection mechanism if we catch the most
common mechanisms and eradicate them
what we will see is a production in
level of resistance in immediately but
few years down the road I fear that we
will see all those uncommon mechanisms
they reach this time perhaps will fit
and if that happens there will be no
more you can afford one set of
recommended drugs for all the different
cases around the clock we will then have
to come up with recommendations that are
region specific perhaps even personalize
sensitivity and specificity for this
reason sensitivity and the specificity
of molecular devices should be assessed
annually this is not being done
currently we still refer to publications
about these devices that were done when
the device was first introduced some of
these days if the devices are years old
and but the bacteria is not static it
evolves constantly and therefore it may
come up with MuNet mechanisms that these
devices can no longer detect we need to
be aware of this and annually assess
this risk this is where I want to start
thank you for your attention this is the
group that I have and I want to thank
every one of them may have played a key
role in everything that I described I
want to also thank our collaborators in
other countries we have been working
with and I'm gonna stop here if there
are any questions I will gladly answer
through email